now Hegel he very famously said that
Africa was a place without history
without passed without narrative did I'd
argue that no other continent has
nurtured has fought for her celebrated
its history more concertedly
the struggle to keep African narrative
alive has been one of the most
consistent and hard-fought endeavours of
African peoples and continues to be so
the struggles endured and the sacrifices
made to hold on to narrative in the face
of enslavement colonialism racism Wars
and so much else has been the
underpinning narrative of our history
and our narrative has not just survived
the assaults that history is thrown at
it we've left a body of material culture
artistic magistrate and intellectual
output we've mapped and we've charted
and we've captured our histories in ways
that are the measure of anywhere else on
earth
long before the meaningful arrival of
Europeans indeed whilst Europe was still
mired in its Dark Age Africans were
pioneering techniques in recording in
nurturing history forging revolutionary
methods for keeping their story alive
and living history the dynamic heritage
it remains important to us we see that
manifest in so many ways I'm reminded of
how just last year you might remember it
the force members of the Al
qaeda-affiliated answer Dean were
indicted for war crimes and sent to the
Hague and one of the most notorious
would up was armored Alf Archie he was a
young Marlon he was charged not with
genocide not with ethnic cleansing but
with being one of the instigators
of a campaign to destroy some of Marley
most important cultural heritage this
wasn't vandalism these weren't
thoughtless acts one of the things that
our FARC II said when he was asked to
identify himself in court was that he
was a graduate that he was a teacher
over the course of 2012 they engaged in
a systematic campaign to destroy
Marley's cultural heritage this was a
deeply considered waging of war in the
most powerful way that could be
envisaged in destroying narrative in
destroying stories the attempted
destruction of nine shrines the Central
Mosque and perhaps as many as 4,000
manuscripts was considered they
understood the power of narrative to
hold communities together and they
conversely understood that in destroying
stories they hoped they would destroy a
people but just as answer Dean and their
insurgency were driven by powerful
narratives so was the local populations
defense of Timbuktu in its libraries
these were communities who've grown up
with stories of the Mali Empire lived in
the shadow of Timbuktu s great libraries
they listened to songs of its origin
from their childhood and they weren't
about to give up on that without a fight
over difficult months of 2012 and Sedin
the of during the answer Dean invasion
Marlins ordinary people risk their lives
to secrete and smuggle documents to
safety doing what they could to protect
historic buildings and defend their
ancient libraries and although they
weren't always successful many of the
most important manuscripts were
thankfully saved and today each one of
the shrines that was damaged during that
uprising have been rebuilt including the
14th century mosque that is a symbolic
heart of a city
it's been fully restored but even in the
bleakest periods of the occupation
enough of the population of Timbuktu
simply would not bow to men like how far
key they wouldn't allow their history to
be wiped away and anyone who's visited
that part of the world they will
understand why why stories why narrative
why histories are of such importance
history matters history really matters
and for peoples of African descent who
seen their narrative systematically
assaulted over centuries this is
critically important this is part of a
recurrent echo across our history of
ordinary people making a stand for their
story for their history just as in the
19th century enslaved peoples of African
descent in the Caribbean fought under
threat of punishment fought to practice
their religions to celebrate carnival to
keep their history alive ordinary people
were prepared to make great sacrifices
some even the ultimate sacrifice for
their history and it was through control
of narrative that some of the most
devastating colonial campaigns were
crystallized was through the dominance
of one narrative over another that the
worst manifestations of colonial
colonialism became palpable when in 1874
the British attacked lia santak they
overran Kumasi and captured the 'santa
he me they knew that controlling
territory and subjugating the head of
state it wasn't enough they recognized
that the emotional authority of state
lay in its narrative and the symbols
that represented it like the golden
stool they understood that control of
story was absolutely critical to truly
controlling a people and the Asante
understood to and they never were to
relinquish the precious golden stool
never to completely capitulate to the
British
narrative matters in 1871 cowl mark a
German geologist working in southern
Africa he stumbled across an
extraordinary complex a complex and
abandoned stone buildings and he never
quite recovered from what he saw what he
saw a Granik dry stone city stranded on
an outcrop above an empty Savannah Great
Zimbabwe and Mao had no idea who was
responsible for what was obviously an
astonishing feat of architecture but he
felt sure of one single thing this
narrative needed to be claimed he later
wrote that the rock architecture of
grapes in Barbary was simply too
sophisticated too special to have him
built by Africans malc like dozens of
Europeans that followed in his footsteps
speculated on who might have built the
city and one went as far as to posit
that I do not think that I'm far wrong
if I suppose that that ruin on the hill
is a copy of King Solomon's Temple and
as I'm sure you know mark he hadn't
stumbled upon King Solomon's Temple but
upon a purely African complex of
buildings constructed by a purely
African civilization from the 11th
century onward but like Leo Frobenius a
fellow German anthropologist who
speculated some years later upon seeing
the Nigerian FA heads for the very first
time but they must have been are
artifacts from the long-lost kingdom of
Atlantis he felt just like Hegel an
almost instinctive need to rob Africa of
its history these ideas are so
irrational so deeply held that even when
faced with the physical archaeology they
couldn't think rationally they could no
longer see and like so much of Africa's
relationship with Enlightenment Europe
it involved appropriation denigration
and control of
the continent it involved an attempt to
bend narrative to Europe's ends and if
Mao had really wanted to find an answer
to his question where did great Zimbabwe
or that great stone building come from
he would have needed to begin his quest
a thousand miles away from Great
Zimbabwe at the eastern edge of the
continent where Africa meets the Indian
Ocean he would have needed to trace the
gold and the goods from some of the
great trading and power of the emporia
of the Swahili coast to Great Zimbabwe
to gain a sense of the scale and
influence of that mysterious culture to
get a picture of Great Zimbabwe as a
political cultural entity through the
kingdoms and the civilizations that were
drawn under its control for centuries
traders have been drawn to that bit of
the coast from as far away as India and
China and the Middle East and it might
be tempting to interpret because it's
exquisitely built beautiful that
building it might be tempting to
interpret it as just an exquisite
symbolic jewel a vast ceremonial
sculpture and stone but the site must
have been a complex of a significant at
the center of a significant nexus of
economies that define this region for a
millennia this matters these narratives
matter even today the fight to tell our
story is not just against time it's not
just against organizations like answer
Deen it's also in establishing a truly
African voice after centuries of imposed
histories we don't just have to
recolonize our history but we have to
find ways to build back the intellectual
underpinning that Hegel denied was there
at all we have to rediscover African
philosophy African perspectives African
history the flowering of great zimbabwe
it wasn't a freak moment it was part of
a burgeoning change across the whole of
the continent
perhaps the great exemplification of
that was sinjar Takata
the founder of the Mali Empire probably
the greatest empire that West Africa has
ever seen
so John Takata was born about 12:35
growing up in a time of profound flux he
was seeing the transition between the
Berber dynasties to the north he may
have heard about the rise of the FA to
the south and perhaps even the dawn the
dominance of the Sola Mayock dynasty in
in Ethiopia to the east and he must have
been aware that he was living through a
moment of quickening change of growing
confidence in our continent he must have
been aware of new states that were
building their influence from as far
afield as Great Zimbabwe and the South's
Swahili sulfonates each engaged directly
or indirectly beyond the continent
itself each driven also to invest in
securing their intellectual and cultural
legacy he probably would have engaged in
trade with these pure nations as part of
a massive continental Nexus of great
medieval African economies unlike all of
those great empires
Sanjar toccata invested in securing his
legacy through history by using story
not just formalizing the idea of
storytelling but in building a whole
convention of telling and retelling his
story as a key to founding a narrative
for his empire and these stories in
musical form are still sung today
now several decades after the death of
Sanjaya
a new king ascended the throne Mansa
Musa its most famous emperor now Mansa
Musa famed for his vast gold reserves
and for sending
envoy's to the courts of Europe and the
Middle East he was every bit as
ambitious as his predecessors but saw a
different kind
of route of securing his place in
history in 1324 Mansa Musa went on
pilgrimage to Mecca and he traveled with
a retinue of thousands it's been said
that 100 camels each carried a hundred
pounds of gold it's been accorded that
he built a fully functioning mosque
every Friday of his trip and performed
so many acts of kindness that the great
Berber chronicler IBN battuta wrote he
flooded Cairo with kindness spending so
much in the markets of North Africa and
the Middle East that it affected the
price of gold into the next decade and
on his return
Mansa Musa memorialized his journey by
building a mosque at the heart of his
empire and the legacy of what he left
behind Timbuktu it represents one of the
great bodies of written historical
material produced by African scholars
about 700 thousand medieval documents
ranging from scholarly works to letters
which had been preserved often by
private households and at its peak in
the 15th and 16th centuries the
university there was as influential as
any educational establishment in Europe
attracting about 25,000 students this
was in a city of around a hundred
thousand people it cemented Timbuktu as
a world center of learning but this was
a very particular kind of learning that
was focused and driven by Islam and
since my first visited Timbuktu I
visited many other libraries across
Africa and despite hagel's view that
Africa has no history not only is it a
continent with an embarrassment of
history it has developed unrivaled
systems for collecting and promoting it
there are thousands of small archives
textile drum stores
that have become more than repositories
of manuscripts and material culture they
become fonts of communal narrative
symbols of continuity and I'm pretty
sure that many of those European
philosophers who questioned an African
intellectual tradition must have beneath
their prejudices been aware of the
contribution of Africa's of Africa's
intellectuals to Western learning they
must have known of the great North
African medieval philosophers who had
driven the Mediterranean they must have
known about and have been aware of that
tradition that is part of Christianity
of the three wise men and in the
medieval period Balthazar
that third wise man was represented as
an African King and he became hugely
popular as the third intellectual leg of
old-world learning alongside Europe and
Asia as appear these things were well
known that these communities did not
grow out in isolation Timbuktu is wealth
and power developed because the city
became a hub of lucrative
intercontinental trade routes this was
one Center in a borderless
transcontinental ambitious outwardly
focused confident continent Berber
merchants they carried salt and textiles
and new precious Goods and learning down
into West Africa and across the debt
from across the desert but as you can
see from this this map that was produced
a little time after the life of Mansa
Musa that there was also a nexus of
sub-saharan trade routes along which
African ideas and traditions added to
the intellectual wealth of Timbuktu and
indeed across the desert to Europe
manuscripts a material culture they
become fonts of communal narrative
symbols of continuity and I'm pretty
sure that those
European intellectuals who cast
aspersions on on on our history
they knew fundamentally about our
traditions and today a strident forces
like answer Dean and Boko Haram grow
popular in West Africa it's that spirit
of truly indigenous dynamic intellectual
defiance that holds ancient traditions
in good stead when Mansa Musa made him
back to his capital he looked upon the
city as the Medici looked upon Florence
as the center of an open intellectual
entrepreneurial Empire that thrived on
great ideas wherever they came from the
city the culture the very intellectual
DNA of this region remains so
beautifully complex and diverse that it
will always remain in part located in
storytelling traditions that derived
from indigenous pre-islamic traditions
the highly successful form of Islam that
developed in Mali became popular because
it accepted those freedoms and that
inherent cultural diversity and the
celebration of that complexity that love
of rigorously contested discourse and
appreciation of narrative was and
remains in spite of everything the very
heart of West Africa and today as the
shrines and the mosque vandalized by
aunt sardine have been rebuilt many of
the instigators of their destruction
have been jailed and we are left with
powerful lessons reminded once again of
how our history a narrative have held
communities together for millennia how
they remain vital in making sense of
modern Africa and we're also reminded of
how the roots of this confident
intellectual entrepreneurial
outward-facing culturally porous tariff
free Africa was once the envy of the
world
but those roots they remain thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]